thank you everyone for joining in first
of all um
yeah so today's presentation is about ml
ops as everyone would have been knowing
prior to the meeting
um
so um
i thought let me just
take around 30 35 minutes to deep dive
everything about mlops probably explain
it from my experience as well and you
know have a discussion towards the end
in the terms of in the form of questions
that you'll probably drop to rachel so
before actually deep diving into the
topic of ml ops which is the machine
learning as an engineering discipline
let me give a quick introduction about
myself
um to all so that that will help you to
connect with me um so this is me on the
right side i'm based out of singapore
and i have been in the data world since
2015. so i've come to singapore to study
my graduate course in data science and
business analytics that's how i deep
dive into the world of data and ever
since that i've just been in it and i
love it absolutely
um since the last couple of years i have
been working in three different
industries primarily advertising banking
and e-commerce that's how i started my
journey
i was an individual contributor in
advertising before i moved to uh roles
of engineering manager
in the banking industry and my recent
experience is that in an e-commerce firm
i'm also important to my beautiful dog
whom i got like a month ago that's her
her name is toffee and uh my email
address is sothejakanuri gmail.com just
in case anyone wants to connect with me
i am also available on linkedin as well
all right so um
let's move on so um the agenda for
today's
uh session primarily is that by the end
of it one would be
able to uh understand or take away the
following aspects which is elements of
machine learning systems
why do we need mlaps
what is the need of mlops and the
benefits of mlops so my entire
presentation is uh
is pertaining to answer these questions
and hopefully everyone has a lot of
takeaways at the end of it
let me move on now so this is just an
introductory slide where i just wanted
to uh
understand from everyone on um i'm sure
that uh whoever is attending the session
at this point
knows the difference between a software
system versus an ml system right well we
know that an ai system actually
comprises of
code and data
unlike a software system which only
comprises of code
and what exactly is the code in the ml
system well it is that of a machine
learning algorithm it which we which we
famously call as the model it can be
either deep learning model or machine
learning model
essentially that's what the code is all
about
right and traditionally programmers
automated that task by writing programs
whereas in machine learning the computer
the system finds and the most suitable
algorithm that fits into the data
patterns and
and is able to produce results in the
form of prediction classification etc so
machine learning system is ideally a
combination
of code and data both
now let me move on and probably uh give
everyone 10 seconds to sort of look at
this diagram and read as many boxes as
possible
okay
um
so i just want to draw everyone's
attention to uh the red box which says
ml code
what what what what can we deduce from
this entire diagram
probably
um only a small fraction of
real time
systems of machine learning is actually
comprised of the ml code
which is shown in the box in the middle
but what about the rest what are the
other processes
well that is the entire surrounding
infra which is
supporting machine learning
algorithms machine learning processes
which is vast and complex
as you see in reality machine learning
team does more than just building the
models they maintain the entire infra
around machine learning right from data
collection
transformation
feature engineering
a b test building in-house tools and
frameworks to serve a solution and a
particular pattern
monitoring retraining etc etc so machine
learning team has to do
more than just figuring out which
algorithm works they need to ensure that
the entire process is repeatable the
entire process can be seamless and it is
fast to delivery
apart from apart from
ensuring that
the models are
can be quickly deployed to production
one also has to understand that a
machine learning team is spending a lot
of time in the technical debt as well
where the data is changing probably the
machine learning uh
sorry the code probably has degraded
based on the user behavior the
demographic the demographic behavior so
what do we do when certain behaviors
have changed so machine learning team
invest in
retraining the machine learning models
to keep them up to date
all of this is something i'm gonna deep
dive further into the slides so if
anyone has probably is fuzzy
at this point uh please don't worry i
will go through each and every term in
detail which will give you great amount
of idea on uh what exactly i mean so all
of these processes which are being shown
right now this actually leads to a
practice in engineering which has been
coined practiced a lot right now across
all the industries and this is called ml
ops
which is machine learning operations
essentially does application of devops
to the ml world and the nr systems
so what is
the goal of mlaps if you can see the
crisscross diagram which goes front and
back
in the slide in front of you it says
that you know
designing training running again going
back forth and you know coming from it
it's a slide like a spike it's a wave
like a spiral right so that's what is
mlobs all about
it's basically ensuring that there is
faster experimentation and model
development
there's faster deployment of upgraded
models to production
and when doing this there is quality
assurance provided once the machine
learning models have been deployed to
production
so these are the three aspects that
mlops tackles really well rather it is
supposed to tackle well
how is it done it's something based on
every company's expertise of their
engineers processes technology
let me conclude this slide by saying
that the goal of mlaps is to make
development
and deployment of ml systems systematic
reliable and repeatable
as we go ahead we will realize that
machine learning process is extremely
repeatable apart from the model itself
the algorithm itself but the entire
process around it if we start zooming
out is very repeatable and why don't we
sort of start relying on what devops
engineers have been doing forever and
just implement uh similar aspects with
the lens of machine learning
so that's how the word mlops has been
coined or probably has been uh you know
decibe
now let me move on to uh the typical ml
flow typical ml workflow that every
organization
is following or probably wants to follow
at any given point in time so these are
the eight boxes that i've come up with
uh there can be many but these are uh
good enough for a high level sort of a
workflow which which uh brings in most
of the aspects in a typical ml workflow
so the first one starts with data
extraction
so as everyone knows that data
extraction is a fair is the phase where
we uh select the different data sources
and bring in that those data sources to
data lakes which is the entry point for
data analysts or machine learning
engineers
which where
they can actually analyze the data
and moving on to the second phase which
is called the data analysis phase in
this phase
um
analysts or machine learning engineers
do exploratory data analysis to
understand all the data which can be
probably an input to the machine
learning model
this is the phase where uh the engineers
really get uh
intimate with data try to understand
wrangle it for
building models or for preparation of
data
once the data has been analyzed uh data
preparation becomes a very important
phase for a machine learning activity or
a task which involves ample amount of
cleaning uh
changing
uh
probably changing or splitting the data
itself with respect to chaining data set
validation data sets or test data sets
or apply some sort of complex
transformations just quoting an example
converting categorical variables to one
hot encoding so this is where the entire
chunk of preparation happens
uh before it actually enters into a
modern training phase and
the model training phase is the is the
phase which probably everyone is aware
of
which is choosing the right machine
learning algorithm choosing the right
hyper parameters figuring out which
combination works for the data set that
we have chosen and coming up with a
reasonably good model which can be
tested and which can be deployed
right so um so the
uh the actual output of the model
training is the best model that we have
chosen based on experimentation there
are different tools which actually help
in each and every phase uh the tools are
sort of very standard at this point in
the market
which can be found in different
ecosystems cloud ecosystems
as well like
amazon google or microsoft
now after the model has been decided and
we have come up with the best model
according to that particular place in
time we go for something called model
evaluation where the model is validated
with the test data for its model quality
where the baselines are set some metrics
are measured and finally
we start moving towards a model
validation phase where we decide where
we have adequate information
for uh
for
checking the predictive performance of
the model and here is where we start
getting ready
on finalizing the model which actually
can go into production environments
which is done by the phase called model
serving
so in the model serving phase
the validated model
is deployed to target environment using
automated practices to serve the
predictions
the deployment can be done using
any sort of a micro service architecture
which is really catching up at this
point in ml workflows as well
typically we do it using rest apis to
serve online predictions or we embed a
machine learning model in the form of an
object to an edge system or a device or
it can be a part of a batch prediction
system as well which can run daily or
monthly
whatever the frequency is
and the last and final phase of a great
machine learning workflow is model
monitoring this is
important imperative
to track the performance of the model
once it has been pushed to production
once it is serving in real time because
all the tests which have been done is
generally done on offline data
historical data but we need to know that
at given point in time how well our
model is performing and does it need any
real tweaking in terms of the algo
itself or in terms of data itself to
make changes and go back in the loop the
way uh probably uh
yeah
if you again see this loop the way uh
the loop is there we probably want to go
back again and again to retraining data
preparation
all the other steps based on model
monitoring
so this particular uh ml workflow
answers the question
to us as to why do we exactly need
mlops
essentially
it helps
in every process it helps in all of
those eight processes
it has a
checkpoint around
every input every output there is a
validation there is a cross validation
which happens essentially i have listed
down a couple of pointers as to why
there is a need for mlops which probably
everyone must agree or
or
at this point it helps in
experimentation
it helps in tracking metrics in a in a
process oriented manner it helps in
source control of the code because every
time we figure out the perfect model we
need to be able to track it back
uh in terms of code and in terms of data
we need to track back the lineage for
that we need to we need to
check in both data and code at every
point in time
regularly so that for any auditing
purpose or any governance purpose we
have the data reproducible
also mlops automates the entire
deployment so we do not want to have
manual uh
checkpoints or we do not want to uh
spend a lot of manual ways to do
deployment because that sort of uh goes
against the uh topic of scalability
also uh
mlops helps in monitoring modern model
performance and efficacy at a regular
basis and if something is a miss model
has degraded or data has degraded again
the entire process can be repeated
so essentially
the need for mlobs is to convert each
and every process into a series of steps
or sub-tasks
and essentially keep triggering having a
set of triggers which warrant a change
to maintain reliability and consistency
with this i actually move on to
what exactly is mloff's the definition
right so it is not a product that we can
buy off a market probably and deploy it
there are at this point uh some tools
frameworks which
which provide
most of the mlaps processes
but typically it's not a product which
you can deploy because it is actually a
process which we need to follow and how
do we follow the process by combining
different tools available in the market
choosing which one is the right one
based on the various competing tools
available
and then plugging it into our ecosystem
based on the industry the maturity of
the industry that we are in and ensuring
an automated uh pipeline of triggers is
run to maintain the entire mlobs uh flow
so it is and it is the entire process
around integration training and delivery
and it needs different
teams to come together to ensure this so
let me quote certain teams which
actually need to come together to set up
the entire mlobs in the organizations so
first one is definitely the entire data
team which comprises of platform teams
engineering teams machine learning teams
we also need the support of the
production support teams because they
help in monitoring they help in alerting
there is also an entire id
infrastructure which need
which
whose support has to be needed just in
case we need more we need different
types of clusters uh which where we can
deploy our machine learning workloads
probably there might be a case where uh
we we need a new infrastructure to be
created all by itself
to help us with our deployments so in
that way
it's a total combination and support of
multiple teams coming together and
setting up the envelopes but the
direction is what has to be given by the
data teams specifically the machine
learning teams there are various
maturity levels of mlaps this is
something which i have i have been
following as a bible from google paper
which is called
mlops by google where they define every
majority level a quick anecdote that i
probably want to give so when i was
working in a banking industry i was
working on maturity level zero and when
i recently made a move to uh
e-commerce industry
i realized that i was somewhere working
uh
on ml ops whose maturity is between one
and two so our eventual goal is to start
moving to two but there are like
different uh
checkpoints as well there is a 0.5 there
is a 1.5 as well so mlops is a process
which continuously keeps getting better
and better based on how much to automate
what to automate the problems that we're
trying to solve
um so it's something which is
essentially has to keep improving we
just cannot make one
flow and
uh feel that probably it will work for
a good amount of time so this is very
very evolving and it's extremely
interesting because google has sort of
laid down the entire foundation and one
can start thinking on top of it
this brings me to another very important
uh topic of ci cd and ct um as i as i'm
saying that ml ops is not a product but
a process so
probably you would be thinking what
process am i talking about right so the
process is all about
uh which has been which has existed in
the past with respect to the devops dev
ops lens which is continuous integration
delivery training so if we just apply
the lens of machine learning on top of
it the definition sort of changes and
the way it has to be done also changes
so let me just probably go through the
most interesting and uh
the new addition to ci cd pipelines
which is the continuous training which
is the third one so this is the new
property which is solely unique to
machine learning systems
um it is concerned with automatically
retraining and serving the models we
have to continuously retrain the models
right because if suppose it's an
e-commerce industry where the the
products are being changed every week
where the user behavior is changing
based on sale days non-peak days etc we
need our models to cater to the changing
data changing patterns that's when
continuous training becomes extremely
important so we can think of continuous
training as
a series of multiple jobs which can be
orchestrated by any orchestration tool
like
airflow where uh the training um
where what exactly happens in training
is that
we look into the data we try out
multiple combinations of different hyper
parameters choose the best model which
fits the current data based on how much
it has changed and come up with the best
model which could be served in real time
so this is what continuous training is
about
another example that when i was in the
banking industry we were not doing
continuous training at all because how
how how often do we open the
banking apps right not as much as we
probably open an e-commerce app and
navigate through the products
also the inventory in an e-commerce firm
is very different than an inventory in a
banking uh
world in banking world there are high
ticket products uh whereas in e-commerce
there are small small ticket products
which have low value so in that way uh
continuous training also depends on the
industry that we are in now let me just
move on quickly to continuous
integration and delivery
so continuous uh integration is no
longer about testing validity testing
and validating code and components for
software systems
instead it is also about testing and
validating data as you remember from the
first slide where ai or machine learning
comprises of code and data so data is
imperative hence integration handles uh
tests the data data schemas and models
and essentially
builds components
builds tested components in the form of
containers executables which can be
deployed further
continuous delivery is all about
continuously
implementing
new pipelines to target environments so
these can be retraining pipeline these
in these serving pipelines just to
ensure that the uh entire
cross an entire uh
entire workloads which are being uh
served in production are fresh uh and
they're continuously integrated with the
changing model and code
this is a quick diagram that i came up
with uh
just to explain how a developer probably
thinks about ci cd and ct so as you can
see um
yeah
okay as you can see that uh when the
developer makes any changes to the code
and pushes it to a github repository for
example
there has to be a framework or a tool
which needs to detect a new commit has
been done
as soon as it detects automatically unit
test cases must be done a container
image must be created and pushed to a
container container image repository
and the branch for the environment where
we want to either be pushed to which can
be
developed in staging or production has
to be ready
and after um
after
the branch is
uh ready to be pushed to a particular
environment there must be another tool
which needs to detect the candidate uh
branch and the changes
and ensure that the downstream uh
ensure that the downstream of deploying
it to the right clusters is done for
example uh we can deploy the container
images to kubernetes cluster
so so this is the process that i'm
talking about how everyone does it is
totally dependent on the rules and
regulations of the industry
all right so i would like to
conclude the three uh step
the three topics that i wanted to take
everyone through with
um this final pointer which is the
benefits of ml ops so it actually
enables scalability and management if we
have one model or two models yes
probably i can do a manual process and
trigger it uh i can trigger all the
changes and manually deployed to
production but if we have but if i have
thousand models then i need a process i
need an automated pipeline around it
so the benefits of mla ops boils down to
these different pointers uh which is
enable small model scalability and
management reusability of ml pipelines
for audit and regulatory requirements
effortless ci cd and also provide data
lineage data lineage is extremely
important for analytics and machine
learning teams both
also
very important is to maintain health and
governance post uh deployment
and finally
mlops is useful for three verticals
which is the people the process and
technology
everyone it's just not for either people
or process or technology
this process is for
each and every
piece in an organization
now i'm gonna take everyone through um
so now now that i've spoken a lot about
the process but probably giving some
sort of an example will actually help
each one of you to understand how to map
all these ideologies and philosophies
into actual action so for that uh
i have picked up
a retraining pipeline from the blog
[Music]
in the company that i work for
where uh
this is how we have uh imagined and
attained uh a retraining pipeline so let
me just take everyone through it so this
will be quite interesting
so um there are a lot of boxes here let
me start with uh the one in the bottom
which is uh
which is marked with red
where airflow is written
so
to keep the models fresh we have to
build retraining pipelines right
and the re-training pipelines can run
weekly daily whatever based on the
industry so if i was a twitter or a
facebook and if i had to refresh my
timelines i would probably
run my retraining pipelines very often
like probably many times a day whereas
if i was an e-commerce industry where i
know that the products change only once
a week inventories probably coming only
once in 10 days i would uh build a
retraining pipeline to run only once in
10 days whereas if i'm a banking if i'm
in the banking domain where i know that
none of my products are going to change
for a long time maybe i don't need to
retrain the model for six months so
the
um
so
so the frequency is something pertaining
to your own industry so what is the need
for retraining
it is uh so there are two needs for
retaining one is for the model to learn
new patterns in data
patterns and data can be uh with respect
to new items on new users and also to
solve the cold start problem of
new items and new users so cold start is
a very common term in machine learning
where when someone is new to a platform
how do we start giving them
recommendations because there is no
previous data for that right so these
are the problems that reach uh
continuous retaining actually helps
so let's move on to the first box in the
left
uh bottom left which is um
how the retraining pipeline actually
starts so we pull the last three months
of data based on our particular use case
uh we convert it into a training set and
a test set it can be a 70 30 split 80 20
80 20
split whatever you want we train a model
using the training set
where after we have trained the model
there is this uh entire component called
ml flow where we can save the model that
we have tuned so what exactly is mnflow
ml flow is an open source platform for
managing the end-to-end machine learning
life cycle
there are many components in ml flow
like tracking projects models registry
all of this help in managing ml flow
ml life cycle and deploying as well so
it's up to us as to which
component we choose so either we can
choose all the components and only stick
to ml flow for model serving or if there
are any problems with ml flow while we
while we're using the tool we detect we
only use the components which actually
map our entire use case
okay so um the new models are saved to
ml flow
um there has to be
some sort of a tool or
a framework here it is jenkins which
detects that there has been a new model
which has been trained so let's compare
against the test data how the older
model is performing against how the new
and the old model are performing with
respect to the test data so for that we
have uh included something called
jenkins this is again an open source uh
framework which helps in continuous
integration and continuous deliberating
so jenkins detects
a change in the
change in a new model or an entry of a
new model to ml flow
uh
validates the model
creates a production tag to the best
performing model it can be previous
model or the latest model that we have
trained
and then what it does is it triggers
a job which pulls the pre
which pulls the model which
that we have decided to be the best
and converts it into an executable
builds a docker image and pushes to
image repository so for codes we have
github for docker images we need to have
a repository right so we're using aws's
ecr
so jenkins is that orchestrator or the
tool
which pulls the production model and
pushes the image repository
it also creates
a pull request
to the github repository
to change the production tags so that
when serving happens the new model
is
uh
hit instead of the older model so once
the
pull request is merged with the help of
a reviewer this is a manual step that we
have
ensured
to keep so that every reviewer is
responsible
um so once the pr is merged there is
another tool called flux cd which
detects a change in the repository
github repository and triggers a new
kubernetes deployment
of the entire model
entire serving etc
so
the components that we're using to
achieve uh deep training
for the entire ml flow
uh sorry mlops is ml flow jenkins and uh
kubernetes flux cd
what else i think that's it
and um
probably if it's a insurance firm or a
banking industry and maybe uh kubernetes
is not allowed deployment to kubernetes
is not allowed it can be a homegrown
cluster right so this entire
box will be replaced by
the cluster that they want to deploy at
whereas if ml flow again is
being open source is not loud this can
be probably replaced by databricks and
airflow
or uh aws sagemaker
so these are the components which can be
moved around
but uh what but how it will be done is
essentially
it actually remains the same it's just
that based on the technical skills or
the industry we can keep changing these
aspects these tools
but
the uh the crux of it remains the same
the entire retraining pipeline is
orchestrated by another tool called
airflow which ensures that all the jobs
run sequentially or with some sort of
dependencies correctly
so um let me just probably discuss on um
there's one more architecture diagram i
want to show before we conclude the
presentation and uh open up for q a
um
which is the model
serve pipeline
so once we have completed the
exploration phase and experimentation
phase of our machine learning models it
is time to make it live
and it is time to build a web service to
serve our models in production
this architecture that you see in front
is specifically for real time
predictions only and not batch so let me
draw your attention to the right side
which there where there is a mobile
phone which says client and then there
is a prediction request fast api service
and vendor ml server so this is what
i'll be uh quickly going through so as
so as and when uh any
user opens a mobile phone
uh and logs into that particular app a
prediction request is sent to a fast api
service which i'll explain and the
request is navigated or routed
to another server which gives
predictions hence the arrows are both
ways and the request is given back to
the client the request can be netflix
netflix recommendations amazon
recommendations or any sort of data that
is shown on the app
so
um
we are serving the model as microservice
as this is the norm of engineering teams
now because the services
can be consumed by other teams so if i'm
a machine learning team i can keep one
service ready and as in when new teams
new engineering teams are built or new
features are built on the app
all of them can consume the same data
so typically we load the model
into the memory of past api
during startup and use the predict
function to throw out predictions every
time a request comes in
this does not scale very well so we use
again again this is an example this
doesn't if it does not scale very well
one can use kubernetes to scale
horizontally and vertically by using
multiple parts
several model frame model serving
frameworks are present
one of the example of model serving
framework is bento ml server that is
being used right now but the panels of
this are tensorflow serving ml slow
serving
one can decide based on their uh
use case the reason we have finalized on
bento ml is because it gives a higher
throughput compared to the other
services
other
serving services it has a feature called
micro matching which essentially
predicts uh predictions on batches of
data and sequentially so throughput is
important for us
it's an e-commerce firm but if it's not
then one can go and choose the other
products as well
so the key components of this diagram is
only on the right side which is the
model serving which is done by bento ml
monkey client service which is done by
fast api fast api is a pythonic
framework and a set of tools that
enables developers to use
a rest interface to call commonly used
functions to also implement machine
learning applications as well
and the entire left side if you see is
the retraining pipeline from the
previous light so essentially all of
these pieces come together and form
different architecture diagrams or
different pipelines this is what i
wanted to
draw everyone's attention to
that um how the previous one amalgamates
so the left side flow runs probably once
a week but the right side flow happens
in a real-time manner each time the
client logs into the application
um
all right so um let me just conclude by
saying that the ci cd and ct which is
integration delivery and training is
done by jenkins
github actions and flux cd these are
different tools
frameworks open source ones
orchestration is done using airflow
um which is very popular
most of the companies do it this way
data sources are typically data lakes it
can be aws s3 or cloudera
whichever or whichever company that you
have onboarded and model tracking and
registry is done using ml flow or
equivalent
this
this is where i come to an end
to my presentation and
i have also
set up some additional
faqs based on the questions i'll just
take everyone through certain slides
that probably can be explained well with
the help of diagrams
so that's it for now
thank you everyone
thank you